[Música]
cada segundo en francia se producen 57
kilos de queso
[Música]
es decir cerca de 2 millones de
toneladas al año se corta se espolvorea
en chispas de oro y se calienta
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en tu los mejores que 0 se afrontan para
obtener el título del mejor que cero del
mundo
12 profesionales llegan de todos los
rincones del mundo
la competencia empieza en el mercado de
tu fe los candidatos cuentan con dos
horas para elegir los alimentos que
acompañarán su bandeja de quesos
la candidata japonesa busca la
pescadería
[Música]
quisiera una rodaja de salmón ahumado y
ahumado
compré salmón porque estoy combinando
con un saber muy
delgada o espesa más espesa así
la ventaja de la quesera es el toque
japonés combinar pescado con queso
en el pasillo de al lado el candidato
norteamericano elige sus productos con
minucia selecciona a los ricos uno a uno
y se degusta también con los ojos en
esta competencia 50% es estética y 50%
gusto
el candidato francés es uno de los
favoritos de la competencia con 31 años
está participando en el concurso por
segunda vez
entonces necesitas hijos me llevaré unos
días
los frutos secos combinan muy bien con
todo lo que esté prensado como el queso
compte o 'el bofo' pero como no sé qué
queso habrá ya trato de tomar
ingredientes que pueda combinar
fácilmente este puede ser el toque que
tenga efecto en los jurados
[Música]
tras las compras se dirigen al parque de
exposiciones de tour durante 8 horas los
candidatos se enfrentan bajo la mirada
del público
[Aplausos]
primer ejercicio la prueba sin mirar el
menú cuatro quesos azul de over me' que
son la estrella de portugal en tibás y
el de suiza el presidente del jurado que
0 de turén y mejor obrero de francia
recuerda lo que los candidatos deben
encontrar
el origen del queso el origen de la
leche el origen del país
el nombre del queso la tecnología de
fabricación y el tiempo de maduración
yo
esta primera prueba que fuerza a los
candidatos a acudir a su memoria
olfativa y gustativa es muy
desestabilizadora e incluso para los
expertos
no era fácil ese pase como más o menos
no sé hay un nuevo conocía el sabor pero
no supe no pude ubicarlo creo que lo
logré con tres de cuatro esta prueba
está basada en su paladar su experiencia
creo que lo hice bien pero siempre puede
haber una trampa
luego viene la prueba 'reina' de la
competencia la bandeja a disposición de
cada candidato hay 70 kilos de queso 100
variedades diferentes los minutos pasan
justin está atrasado
el tiempo se corre tras el tiempo de
cítricos
paralelamente los candidatos tuvieron
que elaborar un plato de quesos tras
bambalinas el jurado evalúa los platos
notan
[Música]
[Aplausos]
preparaciones a veces locas como este
labial de queso comité y su favor y
zador de whisky
la idea es poner de relieve el queso el
acompañamiento que sin matado y sin
hacer desaparece en el queso que es más
que tratamos de resaltar lo sublime
en el escenario la prueba termina a
partir de los mismos quesos los
candidatos crean bandejas muy diferentes
los jurados están entusiastas
es una bandeja que hace soñar con usted
llega frente a la bandeja dice wow esto
es impresionante puede ser un paisaje un
mapa un cuadro o un retrato
tras la competencia los candidatos están
cansados todos esperan con impaciencia
el veredicto
había emociones estoy vacío pero es una
de las cosas más agradables que he hecho
en mi vida
el number one está allá
adrián regule por favor
[Música]
[Aplausos]
estoy tratando de hacer algo a la
japonesa con una idea simétrica
una sorpresa porque durante los últimos
años la competencia ha sido cada vez más
fuerte los belgas los holandeses y los
japoneses llegan con frecuencia al podio
y obligan a los queseros franceses a
afinar su talento con cada vez más
pasión y humildad